I think we should vote for Barack Obama
for a lot of reasons one he's smart too
he has a great voice I mean like nothing
against John McCain but he got a whiny
little voice you know I mean I admire
his history of service and he seems like
a smart funny guy but whenever I eat
whenever he opens his mouth I cringe you
know and Barack Obama has this deep
stentorian voice so no matter what he
says it sounds great so person i just
i'd rather spent four years listening to
barack obama than john mccain I also
think of course I'm not the first person
to say this just having a sort of a
president of mixed parentage you know
Scandinavian and Kenyan sends such a
remarkable message to the rest of the
world and I think that that in and of
itself serves American interests better
than just but anything else we can do
because isolationism has not served us
very well you know we live in this
global economy and especially if you if
we expect China and all these other
nations to continue to sort of fund our
debt you know basically underwrite our
debt they have to like us you know at
least it helps if they like us
especially on a you know on a
manufacturing level as well so I think
Barack Obama is just like a great
ambassador for the United States